we sat down for an exclusive to talk
about all those dating rumors after the
passing of his beloved wife and it's
clear Dewayne is still devastated by
losing Beth they say time heals all
wounds no it don't I thank God that I
had her I would if I went at her there
would be no dog can I take one break and
wipe and get a Kleenex sorry dog
couldn't hide his emotion stopping our
interview three times what do you miss
most about that her comments her touch
or smell she was the glue that held my
family together we're all like kind of
brawling right now so you know the boys
are all good the girls are all in tilt
the reality star says his daughters are
weary of their dad trying to date back
in September dog told me he made a
promise to Beth before she died she said
you better not take my name off your
chest so they'll take that off and don't
get married they'll never be another
mrs. dog moon ager will you marry me cut
to him ten days ago on dr. oz proposing
to his longtime assistant moon who
tabloids dubbed his new girlfriend I
can't you can say no it's all right at
this very moment you proposed
so that moon would say no and end
everything I knew I was gonna do it way
before I done it and I said this will
stop these rumors are you dating her
were you dating her no never
would you've dated her if she wanted a
date yes I've you know I've gotta be
honest with you brother
she said no one will ever love you like
that did the 67 year old's new focus
hunting down an elusive dangerous felon
in honor of bath he says he's got two
guns and all the bullets have my name on
him and this is the last bond that Beth
wrote the tears have turned to blood I
don't want to die tomorrow but I'm not
afraid to I won't get in front of a
train and go hit me but the fear is gone
I've never left a note to my children
and I left him a note this time just a
case this one's for Beth and
gonna make her proud where she could say
that's my big daddy
[Music]